it's time for another check-in with the
drewvan
our road-tripping couple noah and karen
have been making their way across the
country
from california and they'll be joining
us here in new york in a full
a few days but today they're helping us
surprise a very
special small business owner in
washington dc
there they are now but first let's meet
kathy
olefin wilson she's a veteran who
thought outside the box
and turned her passion for giving
presents into a business
with her company blush boxes that
delivers
curated gift boxes and kathy is joining
us now along with abc7 reporter and our
good friend of the show
kiddo shay
hi kids
[Laughter]
hi drew oh my god i can't believe i'm
meeting you
oh what a wonderful opportunity thank
you so much feel the exact same way and
kid i'm always happy to see you
great to see you again drew thank you
for having me back beautiful kathy
please tell me about your extraordinary
small business
and how it came about so drew i decided
to start my business about a year and a
half ago
right before the onset of covet because
i wanted to utilize my gifts
my passions and my abilities to give
myself back into
back to the planet i really wanted to
make sure that i was operating in my
gift and transitioning from
my career to my calling i felt like it
was important for me to
again give my gifts and my talents to
people and to
help them deal with the stresses that
we're currently experiencing right now
absolutely incredible i love that we
would be
honored if you would join our little
book of small
businesses gift guide
if you go to the drewberrymore show.com
you'll be seeing kathy's
amazing blush boxes featured and then it
will live permanently
on our website for everyone to see and
go to
thank you so much how cool is this so
cool
by the way cassie have you heard about
our drew van i sure have
noah and karen just pulled up with
something special for you
they are here look at that
[Laughter]
it's five thousand dollars and it's a
donation
to plush boxes the curated
virtual hug kathy we want to help
continue to make your business
the success it deserves to be and is
thank you so so very much oh my goodness
thank you
five thousand dollar check right behind
you all yours i can go back here
you can go back there go touch it thank
you
kid and kathy so much thank you so much
um noah and karen we'll see in new york
soon and to all of you at home
i hope you have a great rest of your day
take all of this goodness
with you it's for you and thank you for
joining us so much
we'll see you soon